gestern im Kanzleramt also keine
Einigung Stillschweigen wurde vereinbart
und damit erstmal einen schönen guten
Morgen Ricarda lang Bundesvorsitzende
von Bündnis 90 die Grünen guten Morgen
ja Sie werden das sicherlich nicht
brechen diese Vereinbarung die Frage ist
aber werden sie vielleicht das Brechen
was sie auf dem Parteitag beschlossen
haben nämlich einen streckbetrieb von
zwei AKW bis maximal Mitte April also
wenn es die Lage
sozusagen wirklich Bedarf würden sie
dann sagen okay vielleicht noch ein
bisschen länger wir haben eine klare
Linie vereinbart beim Parteitag und die
ist liegen ja nicht einfach ausgedacht
weil der Parteitag hat lust drauf hatte
sondern weil sie aus unserer Sicht aus
der Sache heraus begründet ist denn das
ist die Zeiten der die beiden
süddeutschen AKWs mit den bestehenden
Brennstäben weiterlaufen können wenn man
weiter länger gehen würde dann müsste
man neue Brennstäbe kaufen das wäre dann
ein tatsächlicher Investition in
Atomkraft damit würde man das für die
Zukunft zementieren und das ist glaube
ich der falsche Weg für Deutschland und
wenn die Brennstäbe sagen wir mal länger
halten würden bis Herbst 2023 sagen auch
einige ExpertInnen würden Sie denn dann
damit gehen also unsere Info stand war
immer ist das bis ins Frühjahr geht und
vor allem auch dass wir dann im nächsten
Sommer die Möglichkeiten geschaffen
haben können und natürlich auch
weiterhin Schaffen von allen
cheatterminals über Ausbau andere Sachen
dass wir es wirklich auch hinbekommen
das finde ich darauf angewiesen sind das
heißt für uns geht es wirklich um diesen
Zeitraum bisschen früher aber noch mal
nachgefragt wenn die brennstrebe länger
brennen könnten dann würden Sie sagen
okay da gehen wir mit nein wir haben uns
geeinigt bis zum 15 April also bis ins
nächste Frühjahr dass es unser Angebot
mit dem wir es auch in die Verhandlungen
in die Koalition eingehen können Sie
denn den Bürger und Bürgerinnen jetzt
verlässlich sagen das ist dann
tatsächlich keine Probleme gibt was den
Strompreis anbelangt als auch die
Energiesicherheit wenn am 15 April 2023
keine AKW mehr laufen hier müssen wir
einmal zwei Sachen unterscheiden das
eine ist tatsächlich die Frage der
Versorgungssicherheit also der
Netzstabilität da haben wir extra einen
Stresstest gemacht wir haben immer
gesagt wir orientieren uns an Fakten und
da haben wir gesehen dass wir wenn dann
ein Problem bei der Netzstabilität haben
könnten in Süddeutschland wenn in
Frankreich die AKWs weitens nicht ans
Netz gehen was er gerade der Fall ist
und dafür treffen wir jetzt Vorsorge das
heißt wir werden genau das tun die
Versorgungssicherheit sichern die zweite
Frage ist die Preisfrage die Sie
angesprochen haben und natürlich kann
ich mir hier nicht hinstellen und sagen
ich versichere den Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern dass es keine Problem beim
preisgeben wird denn die gibt es ja
jetzt schon die gibt es auch jetzt schon
wo die AKWs laufen denn das Problem
dabei ist nicht die Frage der AKWs das
ist tatsächlich ein kleiner kleiner
kleiner Teil wenn wir über die Preise
sprechen sondern das ist ein strommark
Design dass eine Abhängigkeit vom
Gaspreis gerade im Moment mit sich
bringt oder zumindest eine Korrelation
der durch Putins energiekrieg
hochgegangen ist aber ich kann
versprechen dass wir mit einer
strompreisbremse dafür sorgen können
dass die Bürgerinnen und Bürger das dann
am Ende auch stemmen können jetzt hatte
ich es gerade schon gesagt bei dem
Treffen gestern wurde still zu
vereinbart sie wissen sicherlich ein
paar Details und können die jetzt auch
nicht sagen oder wollen sie auch nicht
sagen aber was wollen Sie denn der FDP
anbieten wenn sie sagen hier rote Linien
sind immer schwierig wenn man sie zieht
dann muss man sie einhalten auch um
sozusagen das richtige Signal an die
eigene Partei zu sein aber was bieten
sie denn an noch mal ganz kurz mir geht
es hier gar nicht darum was ich da
irgendwie in meine Partei rein sende
sondern diese Position ist aus meiner
Sicht die die sich einfach aus der
Realität her ableiten lässt aber wir
haben ja bereits was angeboten das was
jetzt auf dem Tisch liegt die sogenannte
Einsatzreserve das ist ja nicht die
ur-grüne Linie sie können sich
vorstellen wir haben am Wochenende beim
Parteitag darüber diskutiert da gab es
auch sehr sehr viele denen diese Schritt
schwergefallen ist denn natürlich waren
wir immer die Partei die ich dafür
eingesetzt haben dass der Atomausstieg
so schnell wie möglich und auch zum
31.12 kommt und jetzt sagen wir ja der
Atomausstieg kommt aber wir sind in
dieser besonderen Situation bereit über
unseren Schatten zu sprechen um die
Versorgungssicherheit zu sichern das ist
ja bereits ein Kompromissangebot ich
hoffe dass es jetzt von der anderen
Seite auch die Bereitschaft gibt damit
zu gehen dass sie das einhalten sie da
aber auch vereinbart haben hat ja auch
was mit Vertrauen zu tun auf einem
anderen Themenfeld spielen sie glaube
ich gerade mit dem Vertrauen wofür grüne
stehen und zwar geht es um
Waffenlieferungen unter anderem bzw
jetzt ganz konkret an Saudi-Arabien die
Regierung in Saudi-Arabien begeht
Menschenrechtsverletzungen sie ist Part
oder Teil im im Krieg im Jemen und
dennoch halten sie an einer alten
Vereinbarung in Sachen rüstungsreport
Rüstungsexport fest es ist hat was mit
den europäischen Partnern zu tun warum
wir haben ganz klar auf unseren
Parteitag gesagt wir finden jegliche
Waffenlieferungen an Saudi-Arabien
falsch also auch diese Waffenlieferung
jetzt müssen wir schauen wie kann man
Zukunft solche Situationen verhindern
denn was ist ja in dieser Situation
schwierig gemacht habt war das ist eine
Altverträge in einem
Gemeinschaftsprojekt von Europawahl
falsch bleibt falsch genau das haben wir
auch noch mal gesagt aber muss ja
überlegen wie man solche Situationen
Zukunft verhindert und da gelten für
mich zwei Dinge erstens das
rüstungsexportgesetze kontrollgesetzes
auch für Gemeinschaftsgüter gelten also
auch wenn wir mit anderen europäischen
Partnern zusammen liefern und zweitens
müssen wir uns jetzt dafür einsetzen
dass in der EU kein Staat mehr Anzahl
der Arabien liefert wegen der wie es ja
genannt haben verheerenden
Menschenrechtslage sagt Ricarda lang
Co-Vorsitzende bei Bündnis 90 die Grünen
wir haben gesprochen über den
Koalitionsstreit der heute
möglicherweise im Kanzleramt dann
ausgeräumt werden sollten Sachen AKW
vielen Dank für Ihren Besuch heute danke
Ihnen